FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
going to hand it over
to Carolyn and to Matt.
Welcome.
CAROLYN JUNG: Thank you.
This is my baby,
which I did last year.
And I was lucky enough to get
Craig Lee to do the photos.
This is a compilation
of about 54
of the Bay Area's top
chefs-- their stories
and their recipes.
And of course, it includes the
gentleman standing right here.
Chef Matt Accarrino of SPQR.
So I know that you
guys know that Matt
is an incredible cook.
But what you might not
know is exactly how
he came to be cooking as a chef.
He's a very sporty guy.
And when you were
a teenager, you
had an accident playing sports.
And it was actually
a fortuitous thing,
because they discovered
a tumor in your leg
that was the benign.
But had you not
had the accident,
they probably would have
never discovered it.
He had surgery and it was a
really long ordeal to recover.
It basically-- you had to
learn to walk over two years.
And I want you to tell everybody
how Emeril Lagasse changed
the path of your life
during all of this.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Sure.
Well, first of
all, you glorify it
by calling it a sports accident.
Because it-- I actually wanted
to be a professional cyclist.
So I was thinking
in my mind, this
is what I'm going to be doing.
I'm going to ride 500
miles a week on my bicycle.
I'm going to go to France.
I'm going to race in
the Tour de France.
I'm playing Frisbee
outside of high school.
Jump up.
Catch it.
Land.
And this benign tumor
that had been growing
in my femur since
birth-- so I get taller,
it gets bigger-- breaks.
Next thing I know,
I'm on the ground,
on the way to the hospital.
The worst pain I've ever felt
my life, the whole ordeal.
I remember right before
they put me out, they said,
so there's like a 60%
chance that you'll wake up
and your leg won't be there.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh my God.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I'm
thinking, I'm 16-years-old.
What are you talking about?
I wake up, thank God,
leg's still there.
Can't walk for two years.
So all I do is sit around
the house and watch TV.
What am I going to eat next?
I basically had
nothing else to do.
So I got interested in cooking.
It was something I could do.
It was something
I could actually
do without leaving the house,
without going somewhere else.
CAROLYN JUNG: Because you're
watching a lot of cooking shows
on TV.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: So
Jacques Pepin, Julia Child.
And of course, this is
right around the early '90s,
the birth of the Food Network.
Emeril Lagasse is on there,
doing whatever he was doing.
And I go, wow, this guy
is pretty interesting.
I'll write him a letter and see.
Maybe he'll get back to me.
Gets back to me immediately,
which is amazing.
And something that I
always keep to heart now,
when I get letters and things
like that from young students
and people that want
to learn to cook.
And I've oftentimes opened
up my kitchen to people
because he immediately said,
why don't you come down
to New Orleans and hang
out in the kitchen.
So next thing you know,
I'm in New Orleans
cooking with Emeril Lagasse.
CAROLYN JUNG: And
you were how old?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: 18.
CAROLYN JUNG: Wow.
So what sorts of things did he
have you doing in his kitchen?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Well,
he turned me-- there
was this guy Mr. B who used to
make these banana cream pies,
like the best banana cream pie
I'm ever had in my entire life.
All these ever different guys.
There's so many different
things going on.
I was so new to
cooking at the time
that it was-- what I
always tell the people that
work for me now, is that
when you first start cooking,
the learning is
absolutely exponential.
You don't know anything.
So every day you're
learning this crazy amount
of information.
And then as you begin to
get more experience doing
something, you get a little
higher on the mountain.
And you're not learning--
you're learning
how to do the same
things better.
Or how to do something
in a different way.
And maybe you're not learning
something completely new.
But what happened in that
kitchen was eventually,
Emeril kind of came
around to me and said,
hey, you know, you're
pretty good at this.
You should really go see my
friend Charlie in Chicago.
And I'm like, OK.
CAROLYN JUNG: And that
would be Charlie Trotter.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah, that
I walk into the kitchen of
Charlie Trotter, this sort
of famous, very high end
restaurant in Chicago.
And everybody's got
the French toques on,
and all these things.
And I walk in, and I go to
thank him, and there's a locker
and it says, Matthew
Accarrino on the locker.
CAROLYN JUNG: Wow.
That's pretty cool.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Pretty amazing experience
at all of about 18
or 19-years-old.
My cooking career
just moved from there.
I never stopped.
I tried to go back to cycling
for a couple of years,
but I figured out that I
sort of lost the momentum.
You look at the great
races-- and actually I'm
friends with a
number of people that
are professional cyclists today.
It's like a lot of sports.
Your peak years are
between like 20--
I mean I would be
retired already.
I'm 36.
They talk about somebody
being really old
and they're 40 if
they're cycling.
CAROLYN JUNG: So had not
all of this happened,
would you have considered
cooking as a career?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
I always-- even
when I was a kid,
I always said I either
wanted to-- well,
I think I had three things.
I wanted to drive a
train, when I was five.
CAROLYN JUNG: Like every boy.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: And then
I wanted to ride bicycles.
And I wanted to cook.
So those are always my
three things somehow.
CAROLYN JUNG: So I'm
assuming that you
have seen Emeril in the
years that have passed.
What does he think now,
seeing what you do?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I mean, I think
he would think just
like any other mentor.
I've worked for so many chefs.
Thomas Keller, Tom Coliccio.
A variety of people.
So I just won "Food and
Wine" Best New Chef.
And so I was in New York
and I saw Tom Coliccio.
And they're very proud.
Because those are people
that remember you back
at that time when
you did know nothing.
And as you begin
to know a bit more,
I think they're
proud to see you.
And certainly they've
all-- Emeril included--
conveyed that kind of message.
CAROLYN JUNG: Has
he eaten your Food
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Emeril?
CAROLYN JUNG: Yes.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I don't think so.
CAROLYN JUNG: What?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Not
here in San Francisco.
CAROLYN JUNG: OK.
You've got to do
something about that.
Got to invite him
in or something.
So today, you're going
to make something out
of your own cookbook.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Well, it's a variation.
CAROLYN JUNG: For springtime.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
For springtime.
And I wanted to share
with you all a couple
of different
techniques and to cover
what to me might be
more basic things.
To you they might be
completely brand new things.
I don't know how experienced
a cooking group we have here.
So I have an acre
up in Napa that I
grow on for the
restaurant, and grow
a lot of my own vegetables.
Having been born in the Midwest,
grew up on the east coast,
and then eventually came
out to California about six,
seven years ago, I'm
very taken with that farm
to table, but beyond that
to the next generation.
So you're looking at how
can I grow my ingredients.
What, for instance, like
this thing that I brought.
I have all these Calcot
onions which are the onions
that they grow in Spain.
And they bury them in coal.
If you've ever seen this, they
cook and they peel the onion
and eat it with romesco sauce.
So it's very Tony
Bourdain kind of thing.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, so
you're growing those?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
But they eventually
go to flower like this and
the flowers are incredible.
So I'll use those a little
bit for a garnish today.
And then we have some
vegetables over here.
I kept it pretty simple as
far as spring vegetables go.
So some pearl onions.
Right here are some peas.
I've got some tarragon and
parsley from the garden.
Asparagus.
And then some carrots.
One of the first
things-- so we're
going to do some of the
vegetable prep first.
If that's OK.
One of the first things
about vegetable cooking,
or cooking vegetables
like carrots--
so ideally, we're going to make
this gnocchi in a little bit.
And the gnocchi are all sort
of uniformly the same size.
And then, you have this
carrot, and it's a lot fatter
up here than it is down here.
And so it's how
you deal with that.
One of the first
things they teach you
in the French kitchen, or
really, just about any kitchen,
is a called the oblique cut.
And what that cut
does is it's actually
designed to even this
whole situation out.
So what you do, is you
start and peel the carrot.
And you make a cut.
Turn it slightly.
Cut again.
Slightly.
And every time, I'm kind
of rolling it towards me
and making a cut.
I'm producing something.
But the diameter of this
carrot is actually changing.
So you'll see, that for
something that started out
fat at the top, and
slim at the bottom,
if I now take this-- and
let's see if we have one
of those glass-- all
these cuts are now
basically essentially
the same size.
Right?
So you guys can see that here.
And this is a really
important thing
as far as vegetable cookery
goes, because if all of these
are going to be
the same size, that
means they'll all cook the same.
They'll all cook
at the same time.
So no matter what I do with
them, whether I roast them,
or I boil them, they're all
going to come out the same way.
And it always amazes me to see
those little things like that.
Because somebody had to
think of that at some point.
And decided that
was a good idea.
And I don't know who that was.
Yeah, it was Paul
Bocuse probably.
Who knows.
So that's that.
So we have the carrots.
And so I've done
that to some already.
Asparagus is another thing.
So what I like to
do with my asparagus
is actually take all
these little eyes off.
And I don't know if
you guys have ever
had asparagus and eaten
them and found dirt in them,
but especially when it
rains, it makes sense.
If this thing grows out
from the ground like this,
if you get a rainstorm halfway
through this thing's life,
and it's only this tall, the
water drops hit the dirt.
And the dirt jumps
into these eyes.
And then it grows
the rest of the way.
By time it's this big, if
you just cook this thing,
almost uniformly
you'll find dirt.
CAROLYN JUNG: Wow,
I didn't know that.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: So
if you like the grit,
don't worry about it.
But for me, I'll go ahead
and pick all these off.
I can actually see
little bits of dirt
in these from when we had some
rain not a terribly long time
ago.
But we were pretty drought
starved for a while.
CAROLYN JUNG: Do you do the
thing too, where you snap it
and where it breaks
is the natural--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
And it's always
good to know that.
I And we can tell, because I
never let them grow that big.
They only ever get
about this big.
But eventually, they'll
get rather large.
So for these, we're just going
to do these one inch cuts.
And end up again,
with something that's
relatively the same
size as the carrots.
The other one we have
are some pearl onions.
Pearl onion is just a
nice, small, soft onion.
I've already peeled these.
I'll cut them in half.
And then what I like to do,
is just pull the stem end out.
And then you can pop all
the different layers out.
CAROLYN JUNG: By the way,
if you have Matt's cookbook,
you know, and if you've
eaten at his restaurant,
you know he's very meticulous
about his techniques.
In fact, I always
give him a hard time
and he gives me a hard time
back, because I made this pasta
dish from his book, and
I was balking at the fact
that it required
peeling cherry tomatoes.
Which you can imagine the
undertaking that requires.
I'm
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: A
glutton for punishment.
Then we have some peas.
So I have all that stuff ready.
Other things we're going to
use-- some burrata cheese
made with cow's milk
here in California.
Burrata cheese is
kind of a pull, what
they call pasta filata,
a pulled cheese.
Kind of a pulled mozzarella.
And then usually encased
in a very thin layer
of mozzarella cheese.
But it has a nice
creamy aspect to it.
My family still live
in Puglia in Italy.
And it's interesting,
because the first time
I went to go work in Italy,
I worked in the north,
up in Milan.
So I thought I was doing this
amazing thing by bringing them
this beautiful parmigiano that
had been aged for five years.
And only the red
cows were the ones
they milked to make this cheese.
It was the most special thing.
I want to Peck Market
in Milan, which
is an incredible
gastronomic market in Milan.
Bought this thing,
got on the train.
Take the train down Puglia.
Show up.
Hey, look what I got for you.
And they go, that is garbage.
And it's because it
wasn't from there.
They said it's
from too far away.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, yes.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
We don't eat that.
We don't really like it.
But we do have this.
And then they showed me burrata.
This was 15 years ago.
So interesting.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
it was actually--
it was the ingredients
in California.
And that was one reason that
brought you to the Bay Area?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Well, I actually
worked for Thomas Keller.
CAROLYN JUNG: At Per Se?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: It
was about 10 years ago.
CAROLYN JUNG: You were
opening sous chef there?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Opening sous chef.
And they closed
the French Laundry
to bring all of the
French Laundry staff
here from California to New
York to open that restaurant.
And so I got to basically
spent my entire day hearing
all these French
Laundry guys go,
yeah that's a nice artichoke,
but if you were in California,
you would see that
would be much nicer.
It got relatively
annoying after a while
for an east coaster like me.
CAROLYN JUNG: I bet.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
It definitely planted
a seed, where at some
certain point I thought,
I might want to go take a look
and see what that's all about.
I was working for Tom
Coliccio at the time,
running restaurants
for him in New York.
And he came to me
one day, and said,
I'm opening a restaurant in
Los Angeles, what do you think?
I said, sure.
Next thing I know,
I'm in Los Angeles.
And then eventually, up to here.
Up to the San Francisco.
All right.
Gnocchi.
Gnocchi to-- well, I would
imagine, to a lot of people
is potatoes, flour, egg.
And something you try to
avoid making where it's heavy.
This gnocchi is something
completely different.
This is a semolina gnocchi.
We use semolina flour.
It's one of the flours
that I use to make pasta.
All of the pasta that I serve at
SPQR we make in the restaurant.
It's kind of a coarser,
Durham wheat flour.
We use that.
There's no potatoes in it.
There's eggs.
Somebody noticed there
is butter in it before.
And it's basically a
pas de choux style.
So the same thing
that you would use
to make an eclair, or
the same base they've
used to make an eclair is
what this base essentially is.
But we add things like cheese
and the semolina to it.
That's a bit different.
There's no sugar in it.
CAROLYN JUNG: Is it a
little bit more forgiving?
Because I know sometimes
with potatoes--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
It's completely more.
Not only is it more forgiving,
but it's-- beyond a certain few
things, it's actually
very difficult to mess up,
I would assert.
So I have some flour.
I have flour.
Some water and some butter
that's been brought to a boil
here in this pot.
And what I'm going to do,
is this is regular flour.
And then you can
see the color here,
the difference between
the white-- this
is the semolina flour.
So it has a much
coarser texture.
If you guys want to
pass this around.
Hopefully this won't
mess up the recipe.
If you want to start
that down there.
And they can see the
difference between--
and really, it has to do with
the milling of the flour.
So this is very,
very finely milled.
And this is a bit
more coarsely milled.
But they're in some
ways similar, as
far as being flours.
I've just added the regular
flour to this as it's boiling.
And then I'm going to
add now the semolina.
CAROLYN JUNG: Are you getting
your flour from Italy?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Some of it from Italy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What kind of flour?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: We
use double zero flour.
But double zero really
refers to a grind.
So it's a very fine flour.
But any all purpose
flour will be fine.
And really, when they're
talking about all purpose flour,
they're talking
about a flour that's
been balanced in terms
of the gluten content
and the amount of protein in it.
So that you can do a lot of
different things, which means
you could make biscuits
with it, and pancakes.
But you could also
make bread which it.
So you'll notice that because
the water was boiling,
this begins to thicken up.
And it turns into
this sort of paste.
And that's exactly what we want.
AUDIENCE: How high
is your heat turned?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: This one
is all the way at the highest.
But it has to be enough--
the crucial element is
that it's enough
to boil the water.
Because it really requires--
and what's happening in this,
is that the starch has jelled.
The same way if
you make polenta.
This is that same
kind of technique.
So what's happened
is the starch that's
there in the flour
has jelled because
of the temperature
of the water boiling.
And that's created a structure.
And that structure
is what we're going
to harness to make the gnocchi.
And that's why they won't fall
apart when we go in the water.
I turned it off now.
And I just cooked
it until it started
to get a little bit shiny.
And it's obviously very thick.
AUDIENCE: I love your
attention to detail, chef.
You won't even
allow the tape to be
on the outside of the
container that you bought--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Oh yeah.
Sorry
AUDIENCE: --for more
than a second after you
empty out the contents.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
It's a force of habit.
I really stressed that a
lot with the people that
cooked for me, is that
level of attention
to detail and organization.
Because if you're
always doing that,
then we'll tend to run these
containers through the dish
machine.
And then they're all
back in one location.
And so if I ever go back there
and see the tape on them,
it's like-- I
literally, physically
can't walk past it without
taking the tape off.
But then eventually,
they all get
to be the same way,
which is helpful.
This is now ready.
What I'm going to
do, is transfer this.
And this dough is pretty
hot at this point.
We're going to put
it onto the mixer
and let it cool
down a little bit.
Carolyn, why don't you
tell them about the process
of writing your book and working
with those all those chefs.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, my God.
Well, it was quite the
process, because I was only
given three months
to do the book.
And so I really relied
on chefs like Matthew
to meet a deadline that
I forced upon them.
And thankfully, I didn't
nag you too much, right?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I don't
remember any nagging.
CAROLYN JUNG: OK that's good.
It was great that he was very
clear on what he wanted to do.
And the fact that I wanted
recipes that were home
cook friendly, which most of
his recipes thankfully are.
Because you know what
can be done at home.
And you know what is best
done in a restaurant kitchen.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I
always find that that's
a difficult balance.
Because people are always
asking me to give them
recipes that are
home cook friendly.
Like this one, I tried to
make as friendly for you guys
as it could be, so that
actually you might make this.
But my job as a
chef, in my eyes,
is to make something
you can't make.
CAROLYN JUNG: Exactly.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Otherwise,
why would you come out to eat?
CAROLYN JUNG: Right?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: What
good would I be to you?
CAROLYN JUNG: It's got to be
worth the money of going out,
right?
AUDIENCE: If we don't
have a Kitchen Aid,
what else could we use?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
You do by hand even.
You'll be tired
at the end, but--
CAROLYN JUNG: Don't
go to the gym.
Just make this instead.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:You notice I'm
just pausing to let this cool
a little bit.
And then these are some of
carrots and the peas and things
that I talked about before.
And they've all just
quickly blanched.
CAROLYN JUNG: So you come from
a long line, I'm assuming,
of very good Italian cooks?
As far as your heritage?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
It was amazing.
For my 26th birthday I
went to visit my family.
My Aunt Columbina
has this olive ranch
up in the hills outside of
a town called Manfredonia.
And it's beautiful.
It's like the absolute
most picturesque place--
that you're looking
out over the ocean,
Manfredonia is a town
of about 60,000 people.
Or a small city of
about 60,000 people.
And they literally
have the stone wheel
with the donkey for the olives.
And then, we're going
to make the oil.
And so there's
like a carob tree.
And wild capers, wild
fennel, wild arugula.
My-- somebody made
potato donuts.
CAROLYN JUNG: Potato donuts?
Wow.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Ciambella, they call them.
Ciambella.
It was a pretty
unique experience.
But it also was--
basically everything
that I had for my 26th
birthday was sourced
from within five miles
of that location.
So that was an interesting
birthday, to say the least.
CAROLYN JUNG: So at SPQR, people
call it an Italian restaurant.
But what you do is very unlike
Italian recipes and dishes
anywhere else.
How would you describe
what you do there?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I would say I'm
making American
food at this point.
One of the things
that I think, at least
from my historical
perspective, what it may be,
is that there was a
period where if you wanted
to learn about cooking, the
idea was-- and you can rewind
it back to Paul Bocuses
is the sort of father,
French father, of modern
cooking, let's say, right?
So then all these other
people, like Freddy Girardet,
worked for Paul Bocuse.
And then when all
of the people that
were mentors to me, the Thomas
Kellers, Tom Coliccios--
CAROLYN JUNG: Rick Moonen--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
--all these people.
They all went to
France and worked
for that second
generation of guys
that worked for Paul Bocuse.
And brought back
those kind of recipes.
But a lot of them, in
the very beginning,
were learning to
make French food.
Because that's what we
thought the best food was.
And at some certain point,
there were enough chefs,
people like Thomas Keller,
that said, wait a second.
I can honor French
food, but I'm American.
So I'll make this.
And I kind of am
the next generation
of that chef, at least in
my eyes, that now says,
I have this Italian
heritage, I embrace it.
I'm inspired by it.
But I'm American.
I live in California.
And nothing will make
my food more Italian
than growing some
of my own food,
being involved with
those ingredients,
learning how to make as
many things as-- making them
in-house, and all of those
things at the restaurant.
That makes my food more
Italian than bringing
all of my cheeses and
condiments and all those things
from Italy.
Because just cause you
import it doesn't mean it
that you get the right to
call yourself authentic.
I want to be authentically
myself and authentically
American.
I think I kind of
get away with it,
whether people call that
an Italian restaurant.
And I think there's all
these-- it's interesting,
when you look at the
Zagat, or everyone's
trying to classify restaurants.
And it used to be Italian.
And then it was like
Italian North and South.
Which I don't really
know what that meant.
And now we get dubbed
Modern Italian.
So whatever that means.
It's actually-- the fact that
people are grasping for terms
to describe it is a
good thing, because it
means that we're doing
something different.
CAROLYN JUNG: You're
pushing the envelope.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: And
I think that that's
what good cooking
is really about.
And that's what I want
to be doing every day.
And I want to be doing
with the people that
are working with me.
CAROLYN JUNG: Was it a
lot of pressure for you
to step into the shoes
of Chef Nate Appleman
at SPQR, who was
a huge name when
he was manning the restaurant?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I was lucky enough
to be somewhat
insulated from it.
I moved to San Francisco
in 2009 and Nate
had left six months prior to
my arrival at the restaurant.
And had been the opening
chef of the restaurant.
And so when I got
there, I really
didn't know anything
about it and immediately
just proceeded to do whatever
it is that I was going to do.
I've never, never really
looked back at that.
For me, it didn't
make a difference.
I've always just
guided myself off
of doing what it was that I
thought was important to me.
And then I think
for the people that
knew the restaurant
before, I guess
it really bears no resemblance.
CAROLYN JUNG: No, not at all.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Which was probably
as indicative of his
style as it is of mine.
Chefs have very different
styles and can completely
find our way of changing
just about everything.
I've let this cool
off a little bit.
And then, you'll see
that as I start it,
a little bit of the
steam will come out.
And then, I have some eggs here.
Now, to add the eggs in, I'm
going to do one at a time.
And there's two reasons
you want to do that.
It will come out as a thicker
batter, somehow miraculously,
if you incorporate the
eggs one at a time.
Secondly, if you put them all
in at once, you'll wear it.
Because it'll be everywhere.
We'll just start one at a time.
Every egg that goes in
will get incorporated.
It gets a little bit
looser for a second,
and then it'll tighten back up.
Now we're harnessing
this gluten structure
that we created by boiling it.
CAROLYN JUNG: It's a
lot of eggs in this.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: What
happens is, when the eggs poach
in the water, between that
gluten structure and the egg,
it souffles a little bit.
And that souffle makes
really, really very fluffy
and very light.
CAROLYN JUNG:
There's nothing worse
than a very heavy
gnocchi, right?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: So these
are sort of impossibly light
gnocchi.
And the thing I
like about this is,
this batter-- once
we make the batter,
I'll actually invite you guys
come up, anyone who wants to,
and pipe.
It's kind of a fun thing.
It's a good technique to learn.
CAROLYN JUNG: You didn't
know you get to do that, huh?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: But you can
make the gnocchi-- so today,
we're going to make it.
And I'm going to pull it.
And we're going to serve it.
It's kind of poached,
right from the water.
You could actually make
them ahead, let them cool,
and then you can saute them.
And they'll take color
really, really nicely.
So if you wanted
to-- I actually have
a recipe for this
in my cookbook,
where they're sauteed,
and there's a lamb ragout
that they're served with.
So something that would be
maybe a little heartier.
CAROLYN JUNG: So how far
ahead could you make them?
Could you make them
the day before?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: You could
make them the day before.
CAROLYN JUNG: Could
you freeze them?
And then cook them later?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I've never frozen them,
but I'm sure you could.
And see how it comes out.
If you like, you like it.
CAROLYN JUNG: That's true.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Now all
the eggs are incorporated.
And then I have a little bit
of a cheese that we'll add.
This is Parmesan.
Same reason, I'll shut
it off for a second.
Otherwise we'll--
CAROLYN JUNG: So
how old were you
when you made pasta for
the first time by yourself?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: By myself?
I had to be in my teens.
But I remember, actually,
my third grade birthday
party, my grandmother came
from Boston and made pizza,
and pasta.
And all this stuff.
And I had to make
it all with her,
which I thought was
a horrible chore.
And then I cried the whole
day, because I wanted Domino's.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh no.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Because that's
what everybody else had
their pizza parties.
Little did I realize I had,
basically, a master making my--
CAROLYN JUNG: Exactly.
We should all be so
lucky for our birthdays.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
That's what we
get when we're
young little brats.
Right?
We don't know any better.
AUDIENCE: Chef, do you ever
add any seasoning into that?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: The
cheese is sort of enough.
And then I have
seasoning in the water.
So you guys will taste it.
You'll see.
But to me, you can add
a bit more seasoning.
I put a pinch of salt
in the water before.
I don't know if you guys--
AUDIENCE: What would be classic
seasoning [INAUDIBLE] salt?
Herbs?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah, herbs.
You could add the chopped
herbs right into the gnocchi.
Any seasoning you want.
Dried herbs, fennel pollen
would be great in there.
Truffle.
Anything that tastes good.
Actually, we-- have you guys
seen black garlic before?
This black fermented garlic?
It's kind of everywhere now.
I'm remember when the--
Fanny from La Sanctuaire
showed it to me seven
or eight years ago.
And I was like, oh my
God, this is amazing.
And now--
CAROLYN JUNG: Now you
get it at supermarkets.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: It's
at Whole Foods, yeah.
What I've actually
figured out-- and I
was going to show
you guys, but I
figured it would take a little
long, and you need quite a bit
to do it.
But if you peel all
the black garlic
when it comes in the
skins, we save the skins
and put a hot water
over it, and make
kind of a black garlic tea.
It seems wasteful
to throw it out.
And then we actually use
that water, that infusion
with a black garlic
and make a puree.
That really reinforces it.
So I have a little bit of that.
And then summer truffle
season just started,
so I brought a little summer
truffle for you guys today.
So those are some garnishes
that are optional.
But yeah, a lot of things
will work as fold ins
to this batter.
And because you
have this structure,
you could do-- you
could put together
any combination of
seasoning that work for you.
And I think there's
probably a lot of things
that this batter could
actually hold within itself.
And this is just--
I actually had
a German intern my restaurant.
And if you guys have ever
seen this in gnocchi,
where they have it on a board,
and they use a spatula and they
scape the gnocchi
into the water.
You could actually do
that with this dough.
And that would be
another way to do it.
But I would imagine you could
put little baby shrimp into it
or something and do that.
CAROLYN JUNG: So chef, lot
of your mentors-- Coliccio,
Moonen, even Thomas
Keller a little bit,
have had a TV presence.
Would you ever consider
doing Top Chef?
Top Chef Masters,
anything like that?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I've thought about it.
I've sort of been asked
a couple of times.
But maybe it's not my thing.
I don't know.
I really like the aspect
of being in the restaurant
and being with the customers.
And I'm lucky enough that SPQR
is a fairly small restaurant.
And the kitchen is basically in
the middle of the dining room,
for those of you
who have been there.
CAROLYN JUNG: It's
a tiny kitchen too.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: And I
actually like that aspect
where I'm really interacting
with my customers.
And we have-- one of my great
regulars is an older gentleman.
He comes in every
Saturday night.
And I say every Saturday
night, but he-- I think it's
his 300th visit.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh my God.
Wow.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Something like that.
To the restaurant.
This Saturday.
So I'm getting something
special ready for him.
Those are the things that make
me really excited about being
a chef and what I'm doing.
Because you think about
that-- that person
that comes in-- he's literally
there every Saturday.
And he brings me either a the
New York Times or a New Yorker
article to read.
The so the only reason that I
have any culture whatsoever,
or know what's going on
anywhere with anything
will be because he
brings me those articles.
And I read them.
But those are the-- to me,
those are the great experiences.
And another thing about
cooking that has really
been important to
me is the ability
to travel and to do things
like being here today that
add a life experience
dimension to what I do.
I pretty much have-- not
seen the entire world,
but I've seen a lot of
the world because I cook.
To me, that's been a
really important thing
and a really worthwhile thing.
CAROLYN JUNG: What's the best
thing about being a chef?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I don't have to wear
a suit when I go to work.
I have the same uniform.
I never have to worry
about what I wear to work.
I just put on the
same chef coat.
CAROLYN JUNG: That's true.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Right?
I remember being younger
and thinking wow,
I never really want to have to--
CAROLYN JUNG: Put a tie on.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
Worried about going
to work like that.
So it kind of worked
out perfectly.
But I think honestly, some of
the best things about being
a chef is every
day I'm creative.
And every day, I see that
creativity fulfilled.
Because every day
I'm making a dish.
And even though
there are things that
take days and days to prepare,
every day I finish something.
Every day-- and we actually
finish a lot of things.
It's a much faster
cycle than say,
going and looking at a
piece of ground and saying,
I'm going to build a
building here in seven years.
In seven years, I'll be able to
look at my complete building.
I can make that building-- I can
make this dish in half an hour.
So I think that
instant gratification
is a great part about cooking.
And also, being able to
work with all of the people
that work in my restaurant
with me, all of my staff.
And being able to be a leader to
people and a mentor to people.
And to return some
of the favors that
were shown to me when I
first started cooking.
Seeing somebody go through and
know nothing, and eventually
something.
That's pretty gratifying.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
conversely, what's
the worst thing
about being a chef?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: The opposite
of everything I just said.
CAROLYN JUNG: The
opposite of everything.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
The hours are long.
And the task is always arduous.
So I think it's one of those
things where sometimes-- it's
one of those careers that--
people say the restaurant
industry is very difficult.
It's because it demands a lot.
And you always have
to put into it.
I think there are
a lot of careers
that are actually like that.
But you're only as
good as your last meal.
So you can never
really-- go this way.
You can never really rest
on your laurels as it were.
The batter I
transferred to the bag.
And then, I don't know
if you guys noticed that,
but this is a little
trick that I do.
When I first started
cooking, we used
to have these
canvas bags that you
could use over and over again.
We never use those anymore.
We always use this.
And actually, we'll rinse
these out and reuse them.
Because I feel pretty terrible
about throwing plastic
in the garbage.
Cause it basically goes nowhere.
It goes to some
landfill somewhere.
CAROLYN JUNG: So if someone
doesn't have the tip,
could they just use a Ziploc
bag and cut the end off?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
But these kind of
tips are inexpensive.
They only cost a couple dollars.
They're a really
good investment.
As is this thing, which I use
to flip things over in a pan.
And you're going to see me
use it to cut the gnocchi.
Things like little-- these
are actually sewing scissors.
Joyce Chen, right?
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh my God, really?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: We
use these in the kitchen
for a lot of things like that.
CAROLYN JUNG: Are you
a big tweezer guy too?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I
left them at home today.
For you guys.
What's funny is
that the tweezers--
that whole thing
is really about,
if I'm trying to place a garnish
into a dish and my fat little
fingers are going
to mess it up--
CAROLYN JUNG: Or if
you're shaking at all--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: --it's
better to use a tweezer
to do that thing.
And so if you're
really trying to make
these elaborate presentations
or elaborate constructions,
sure that thing is helpful.
But I don't feel compelled to
put every single thing that I
touch on the plate
with a tweezer.
But it's definitely
a helpful tool.
It's just like anything else.
Having the right tool for
the job is a huge benefit.
If there's anything
that you've ever
tried to do where you
didn't have the right tool
and took about 10 times
longer because you didn't have
that tool, you appreciate that.
CAROLYN JUNG: I'm
sure they can relate.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Transfer this to here.
And then, if you got
up to this point,
and you wanted to serve this,
and it was dinner party,
you just come back later.
As long as you have
the water ready,
this is-- I mean eventually,
there's eggs in here.
You don't want to leave it
out for a couple of days
or probably some kind
of fermentation project
would start in there.
CAROLYN JUNG: Fermented gnocchi,
it could be a new thing.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
For an hour it's fine.
And so it's just lightly warm.
And then, basically
I'm going to bring
this over the simmering water.
There's salt in here.
And then, what I
figured out is, you'll
see, if I'm tapping--
I'll just start.
Gentle pressure on this.
Then you could sit
here and just tap.
What's actually happening is I'm
aiming for the tip of the bag.
But they handle of the
wood is hitting the pot.
So that's what's stopping it.
You'll notice if it's like
this, it's a little bit harder
to hit this target for me.
CAROLYN JUNG: Is there
an ideal size for these?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
About two inches.
And eventually you can stop
and reassess where you're at.
I'll do a few more
and then we'll
open it up for
somebody else to try.
AUDIENCE: Will the gnocchi
shrink quite a bit?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Nope.
They'll stay just like this.
Whatever size they go in
here as, they'll stay.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: This batter
would be too loose to do that.
So this is that totally
different style of gnocchi.
If you wanted it to be
a little bit bigger,
you could change the tip
to a larger pastry tip.
And that would give
you a different style,
or a different size.
Who wants to try?
Come on around.
CAROLYN JUNG: So have
you done this before?
WOMAN: No.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
You can't mess it up.
WOMAN: Like this?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Turn this one this way.
Are you left-handed?
WOMAN: I'm right-handed.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: You
might want to switch.
WOMAN: Yeah.
I was like--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I'm left-handed.
I won't handicap you.
Yes, a gentle pressure
and then whatever
it looks long enough--
if you start to get--
see how you have this on here?
Just dip this in the water.
Go like that.
And it'll clean it.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
what do you think?
Should we hire her to do
this here every lunch time?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
For sure.
It's a fun little thing.
And like I said, you can flavor
it a lot of different ways.
WOMAN: If they get
all around, should I--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I'm going fish
them-- I'm going to go fishing
for you in two seconds.
And that's what I
like to use this for.
I can actually go in here.
And all the ones
that have floated now
for a minute they're
all ready to come out.
And you'll see that
they have-- this
is what I was
talking about before.
Where you could actually make
them to this stage and then
pull them and leave
them like this.
And that's what I have.
I prepared some this morning
for you guys already.
For after this.
WOMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Yeah, of course.
And these are some of the
ones that I made this morning
so you could see-- very similar.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Nope.
Yeah.
And that's the
great part about it.
So if these-- I didn't
add anything to these,
but if I go and I touch
them-- and actually,
you guys want to--
WOMAN: Mine aren't
as good as yours.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I have
a little bit of practice.
You guys want to
check these out.
Those were the
ones that are made.
And so they have a
certain density to them.
And a certain texture, but you
could eve eat them like that,
but you'll see that
they're pretty light.
This is a good chef trick.
I'm going to steal some of
your seasoned cooking water.
CAROLYN JUNG: So is this
on the menu a lot at SPQR?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: We
have it on the menu
with the lamb ragout right now.
And we do different
variations of this
throughout the-- but
one of my favorites
is to do just fresh
out of the water.
And then during
truffle season, we just
do truffles over that
and Parmesan cheese.
CAROLYN JUNG: That
sounds amazing.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
She's tenacious.
CAROLYN JUNG: I know she's--
I think you should hire her.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I already did.
You're fast.
WOMAN: Why'd you say
that, I screwed up.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I
won't say anything.
CAROLYN JUNG: Don't
listen to him.
WOMAN: You're just like my mom.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I
added just a little bit
of the cooking water
here and some butter.
I'm going to warm all these.
And then we'll add in-- I
have some chopped tarragon
and chopped parsley.
And then we're going
to do a few-- we're
going to use your nice gnocchis
for the plate up today.
CAROLYN JUNG: So what's the best
advice a chef ever gave you,
and who was that gave it to you?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I've
gotten so much advice.
We call it feedback.
CAROLYN JUNG: Feedback.
OK.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Who knows.
I feel like a good chef will
give you advice every day.
I always tell my guys that I
see somebody-- so last night,
I asked one of my cooks
to take something upstairs
and lay it out flat on a tray
like this and then come back.
And so he went upstairs
to get the tray
to bring it down for the stuff
so that he can then go back.
And so you just decided to
make two trips for something
that required one.
If you do that 100
times a day, you
will have just wasted an
hour of your day running
back and forth,
getting nothing done.
So if you apply that across your
entire career, at this point,
that's a lot of wasted time.
CAROLYN JUNG: That is.
It adds up.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: That
little kind of stuff
about something
that's constant--
CAROLYN JUNG: Being efficient.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Good job.
Thank you.
What's your name?
WOMAN: Katia.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Katia?
Thank you.
Anybody else?
I can refill this thing.
CAROLYN JUNG: Anybody
else want to try?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah, we
print the menu every day.
And I always liken it to
the tracks of a caterpillar.
Half of them are on the road
and the other half are not.
So there's probably
40 or 50 menu items
and then we're
running 25 of those.
So we're always coming
up with new menu items.
Let me turn this up
a little for you.
And then those new menu
items, some are new,
some were on three days ago.
And we bring them back.
We're always doing
different things
and bringing in-- a lot
of what is important to me
in the restaurant
is things like,
pretty much all the
animals that we buy,
with the exception of
beef, we buy whole.
So that means if
I get a duck, I'm
going to get duck fat
and a duck tureen,
and duck breast, and duck legs.
And all these different things.
And then we use all the
bones and we make broth,
so that begets four
or five dishes.
But once we run out
of duck breasts,
we're working with duck
leg to do something else.
And so there's always
new dishes and always
new things coming because of
that search for ingredients.
Or if I go and all these
onions are flowering right now,
but in two weeks, they won't be.
So in two weeks, we couldn't
even use that as an ingredient
if we wanted to.
That kind of change in things.
CAROLYN JUNG: Is there
any new ingredient
that you've discovered lately
that you just love and can't
get enough of?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
It's hard to discover--
I wish I could discover new
ingredients more often than I
do.
But it was interesting because
I went to this great trouble
to get this certain
type of ice lettuce,
or some type of ice plant.
I had to go, and think I
got it from a guy on eBay.
And it was a little--
CAROLYN JUNG: A guy on eBay?
OK.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
--kind of sketchy.
And then I went
around the corner
from where I'm growing in Napa,
and it's on somebody's lawn.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh, jeez.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: And somebody
planted it as an ornamental.
It was edible.
And so I kept
thinking, I'm going
to go back to that guys
yard in the middle of night
and cut that stuff.
See, you're good.
But I think you're
always looking
for new ingredients and
new ways to use things.
I think that's also one
of the great joys of being
a chef is that you're
bound to come back
to stuff over and over again.
Because every year, corn
comes, and tomatoes come.
I've started to
actually consider
tomatoes in the last two weeks.
They're not really
ready yet, but--
CAROLYN JUNG: Everything
is coming early this year.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Yeah.
But all of the tomatoes
that I have growing
are all starting to get there.
But first, we'll think
about green tomatoes.
And then we actually
make a tomato leaf pasta
at the restaurant.
CAROLYN JUNG: Tomato leaf pasta.
Wow.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I
asked one of my farmers
one year to pick me 20
pounds of green tomatoes.
And his guys picked 20 pounds
of green tomato leaves.
And they sent them to us.
Which, I don't know if you--
but 20 pounds is a lot.
I kind of felt badly.
And we had a long talk about
it and then eventually decided,
you know, it'd be
better to figure out
what to do with these
than throw them away.
So that came out of that.
But I think a lot of times
that's another great thing,
is that a lot of times
mistakes become the ideas.
If you learned something
from a mistake,
it becomes the next new idea.
Looking for new uses or new
ways to use an ingredient
is just as beneficial as knowing
what you did the year before
and trying to do something
different based on that.
CAROLYN JUNG: That's looking
beautiful, by the way.
AUDIENCE: How much
time do you spend
on creating brand new recipes?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: We
call them paradigms.
So it's like adding something
to the vernacular in my kitchen.
We'll have this
thing and it's wow,
I have this idea about--
so we make lasagna.
And so I can't make
lasagna the way
that everybody
else makes lasagna,
so I have to do this 27
layer, where we bake it
in this special tureen mold
that had a stainless steel
guy make for me.
So that we can lift
the mold off and then
it has all these layers.
So we've done that with all
these different variations
of the dough and the filling.
But then at one point, we wanted
to do something different.
And so I was like, all
right, well, what is lasagna?
Lasagna is this layered thing.
What is lasagnette?
And lasagnette is a thin
lasagna noodle in Italy
that is usually something
that's eaten as a noodle pasta.
And I don't know why they
would call it lasagnette,
but so it's like, all
right, so what if lasagnette
was a thin lasagna?
And so we took
this sheet of dough
and we fill it and
fold it and bake it.
Right now, we're
doing one that's
filled with ricotta and saffron.
It's a saffron dough.
And it looks like
a little envelope.
And then on top, we do a
mushroom bolognese with it.
Those kind of things,
where you just--
CAROLYN JUNG: How long did
it take you to perfect that?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: A day.
CAROLYN JUNG: A day?
That's it?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
But then what'll
happen from there is, we'll
change that lasagnette--
the filling, the
dough, the topping, all
the different accompaniments.
And it now has-- Good job.
CAROLYN JUNG: Look at you.
You're like a
machine over there.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Zero
supervision, by the way.
If you guys noticed that.
CAROLYN JUNG: Pretty good.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
But now that'll
beget 25 different
iterations of that same idea.
And so adding that new idea to
the thing, where at one point,
we buy a certain
bread for the tables.
And then as a restauranteur,
even if you're buying bread
for the tables, no one's--
they were talking about loaves
of bread that nobody cuts.
So we have it.
We buy it for a day.
Nobody even asked to eat it.
So you would just throw
it away, because what am I
going to do with
it the next day.
So at some certain point,
we're like oh, what can we do?
How can we not
waste this product?
Because somebody lovingly
prepared that product.
So as a chef, you're really
trying to make the best out
of everything that you buy.
We came up with
this idea for what
we call the budin de pane,
which is bread pudding.
So again, here comes into play
this sort of mold like this.
And we take brioche that we
make and run it on a slicer.
So you get these long
planks of brioche dough
and put that in the bottom.
Take all these loaves.
Cut all the crusts off.
Use all of that.
And right now we're
doing it with apricots
and white chocolate.
We make a white
chocolate custard
and soak that whole thing.
Put this layer of
cubed bread in there.
Press it down, and then take
another layer of that brioche
and put it on top.
We bake that whole thing.
I had a plastic maker cut
these perfect plastic weights
so I could perfectly
weigh the thing down.
So we get this insanely
perfect huge block
that we can then portion
into bread puddings.
CAROLYN JUNG: That's the most
refined bread pudding ever.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Dip it in sugar
and the we caramelize
it one more time.
And it has a crunchy sugar
exterior, like a creme brulee,
on a bread pudding.
And it's made with that.
But that's basically
made out of what
we would call trim for the
interior part, which is bread
that we didn't use
from the day before.
Those kind of
things we're always
looking at, and trying
to put innovation
into something that
you already have.
Those kind of new
ideas is what's
really important in a kitchen.
So I'm always trying
to instill that
in the people that
are working for me.
Because it is one
thing to go and look
for a completely brand new
thing that you have to acquire.
But what if you could do more
with what you already have?
And so I think that's a
really important concept
across, I think, a lot of
disciplines, especially
cooking.
AUDIENCE: I know that the major
part of a lot chefs' careers
is [INAUDIBLE].
Do you still have
time to do that?
Or is that something [INAUDIBLE]
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Regrettably,
as you become a chef,
it's more difficult,
I would say.
I always say to the guy-- I
have cooks that one day want
to become a sous
chef, and they say,
well chef, I've cooked
for you a couple years,
I'd like to become a
sous chef and move up.
And I say, I just want you to
understand that the shift will
go from where you're learning
all the time to you're now
learning a lot of the
time, but you're also
teaching a lot of your time.
And then you get the
point where I'm at,
and I spend more time
teaching than I do learning.
So it's really difficult
for me to get--
and actually Google
is a big help,
because every time we're
looking for-- if I have an idea,
I can actually Google
the ingredients and see.
And you'll see what
other stuff comes up.
And then you try not to copy
that or do those things.
But it gives you
some inspiration.
And so I think in
the real world,
where I'm doing
that is I'm going
and I'm spending a day here.
Or I'm going, I'm traveling
and cooking with other chefs,
or doing other events and seeing
what other people are doing.
And you're trying to soak
up the world around you
to re-purpose that
experience for inspiration
in your own realm,
in your own kitchen.
I think it becomes certainly
much more closed off
the more you are chef in
charge, at that point.
Because nobody is going to
come tell you, hey chef,
I've got this brand new recipe.
I'm going to give it to you for
you to put in your cookbook.
It like, no, you better
figure out your own stuff.
That's definitely
an aspect of it.
CAROLYN JUNG: So
if you could choose
to stage with any chef living
or dead, who would it be?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
God, I don't know.
I guess going back to that
thing-- I would have liked
to have gone back to--
both of my grandmothers
were incredible cooks.
And I was too young
and too foolish to know
that I should have
spent more time trying
to figure out what they knew.
And my grandmother
actually gave me
one of her cookbooks, which
was like the Farmer's Almanac
Cookbook from the '40s, but
she had made all of her recipes
and all of her notes in that.
It was in my father's
basement and it
was destroyed in
Hurricane Sandy.
It was the one thing
that I was probably
the most upset about losing.
And we really tried--
we stayed in hotel room.
We traveled there, because
I live here in California,
obviously.
So when that happened in New
Jersey in my father's house,
we traveled and spent three
days with hair dryers and irons,
trying to dry stuff
like that out.
Whatever the water was, there
was something not right.
So we ended up saying,
got to get rid of it.
But I tried to take pictures
and document what I could
before we got rid of things.
It would've been
a good experience
to have spent that stuff.
And like I said, it goes back
to that third grade birthday
party where I should
have been paying
a little more
attention to the pizza.
Because I would have benefited.
This is another
little handy tool.
I don't know why
it has a mirror.
I would love it if sometime
somebody would tell me.
I can't possibly figure it out.
CAROLYN JUNG: So you can
check your makeup in between--
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
I mean, is that?
It makes no sense to me.
But it seems an odd-- so
have you seen these before?
They're-- you can get them at
Dyso or one of $0.99 store.
CAROLYN JUNG: The
Japanese Stores.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: We go by
Clement Street and buy them.
And they're like $1.00.
This is perfect for little
a la minute garnishes.
This is just a little
bit of truffle.
So These are summer truffles.
And usually they have
a black exterior.
And I really like to
peel the outside off.
And we use the outside
and chop it up.
And then we lightly cooked
this in mushroom stock.
A little bit of summer truffle.
And then this is that black
garlic puree to just finish it.
AUDIENCE: Chef, what
is one thing that you
can eat for the
rest of your life?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
One thing that I
could eat for the
rest of my life?
Cereal.
CAROLYN JUNG: Cereal?
Any particular kind?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Cereal and yogurt.
No, we actually make
granola at home.
And I hit the bulk
bins at Rainbow Grocery
and Whole Foods and things.
And then we use-- my girlfriend
has a little bit of a gluten
thing that she's
trying to work through.
And so we're using
coconut sugar and maple
syrup and all these other
things to make different things,
and experimenting with
the different tastes.
But I actually really like it.
And we eat a lot of fruit,
yogurt, and granola.
CAROLYN JUNG: That's
pretty healthy.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
It's what it is.
But this is what you guys made.
CAROLYN JUNG: Pretty good, huh?
[APPLAUSE]
So I know you still cycle a lot.
In fact, you are doing a ride
with Chef Chris Cosentino
later this year?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I'm actually
doing a couple different--
so I'm still on the
bicycle quite often.
I'm going to Aspen Food and
Wine because I have the Best New
Chef Award this year.
And so I will be riding
from Leadville, Colorado
70 miles over a mountain pass.
CAROLYN JUNG: At high altitude.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: At
12,000 feet or something.
So I'll be--
CAROLYN JUNG: Have
you done this before?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: No.
I haven't ridden over
this pass before.
I think we start at
around 7000 feet elevation
and head up to 13-- 12 or 13,000
to get to Aspen Food and Wine.
There's a couple of pro-cyclists
and a few other riders
that are coming
that will certainly
attempt to challenge me.
I have no doubt.
But then also in the
fall, the Sonoma Century
with Chris King, who is a
bicycle component manufacturer,
used to be based here in
California, is now in Portland.
Chris Cosentino and myself, a
chef from the Glen Ellen Star,
and a few other people are
going to be cooking for that.
So I get to make
lunch for 450 people.
That should be fun.
CAROLYN JUNG: I know
Chris also had dreams,
at one point, of becoming
a professional cyclist.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: And he did
mountain bike race for a while.
CAROLYN JUNG: He did.
24 hour ones, too.
So any rivalries
there on the bike?
Any side bets happening?
At who's going to win?
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I think
it's all friendly competition.
I think we'll all
just have a good time.
And I'm also headed to
Greenville, South Carolina
later this year for--
George Hincapie used
to ride with Lance Armstrong
on the Tour de France and all
these other things, now
has his own company,
Hincapie Sportswear in Carolina.
And he does a big
ride every year.
So I'll be going down
there to cook and ride.
I think, again,
life is about trying
to find the things that you
love to do and get paid for it.
So if-- get paid for doing them.
So if I can combine cycling
and cooking together,
that's the best of
both worlds for me.
Anytime I can do
that, I'm fair game.
I'm game for it.
CAROLYN JUNG: So before I
let you guys all sample this,
cause we're going to
have samples later.
And we're also going to do
a book signing afterwards.
I always like to close the
interview by doing a little fun
word association with the chefs.
I'm going to say
something and I want
you to answer with the first
word or phrase or thought that
comes into your head.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: I can't wait.
CAROLYN JUNG: OK.
You're a good sport.
Chefs on social media.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO:
Too much free time.
CAROLYN JUNG:
Restaurant critics.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Uh oh.
CAROLYN JUNG: The feeling
of fresh pasta dough
in your hands.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Supple.
CAROLYN JUNG:
Italian restaurants
that can't be bothered with
making their own pasta.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Lazy.
CAROLYN JUNG: The
James Beard Awards.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Prestigious.
CAROLYN JUNG: The
Tour de France.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Difficult.
CAROLYN JUNG: Thomas Keller.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Hero.
CAROLYN JUNG: Julia
Child Cooking Shows.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Entertaining.
CAROLYN JUNG: Lydia Bastianich.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Mama.
CAROLYN JUNG: And
last, but not least.
Chef Boyardee.
MATTHEW ACCARRINO: Do not open.
CAROLYN JUNG: Oh!
Well, thank you so much.
And you guys have any questions,
please jump, feel free.
[APPLAUSE]